we remember Broward County Sheriff Scott
is really thoroughly discredited himself
with his handling of the parklands
shooting we're at a scene and
gun-control rally he attempted to vilify
gun owners as a group while
simultaneously keeping credit on himself
like a megalomaniac now sheriff Israel
is facing a vote of no-confidence from
his own deputies Jeff Bell is a deputy
sheriff and president of the Broward
Sheriff's Office deputies Association
and he joins us tonight mr. Bell thanks
for coming on thank you for having me so
facing a vote of no-confidence for what
why do you have no confidence well
there's a series of events that have led
up to this vote of no-confidence and it
has nothing to do with a contract
whatsoever that is a blatant lie by the
sheriff himself but this is about a
series events over the past couple years
such as a bad policies of the promise
program in a civil citation program that
takes all discretion away from deputies
to make the arrests that we need to make
it's about the the lack of training
facilities not having our own gun range
to properly train for these situations
it's about to distrust between the
Sheriff's Office and the Union when the
sheriff's office asked for our help to
raise property taxes on citizens because
they claim to be broke but yet well want
only to find out after completing an
audit that the sheriff's office returned
one hundred million dollars back to the
County Commission alone last year and
then it's the discovery of the misuse of
taxpayer money by the Broward Sheriff's
Office by providing private entities
such as NAPA Auto Parts with free gas
cards from the sheriff's office where
we've identified through public records
requests that they in one year alone
they obtained six thousand gallons of
gasoline from our gas pumps that is a
fleecing of Broward County and then also
on top of that the disparity of
treatment and punishment between the
command staff if they are to commit
felonies and untruthfulness compared to
what deputy as a far great timespan of
what punishment we will get between the
rank-and-file
and the command staff so what should
have led to this no coming well that's a
that's quite a lid name and what you're
describing is a combination of
incompetence in corruption call me
cynical but when you watched sheriff
Israel lay the entire blame for the
shooting on middle America because
ordinary law-abiding people have too
many guns in his view did it seem like
an effort to distract from his own
failures absolutely it was and you can
see this pattern of this
there's Sheriff Israel back in his own
Facebook post from February 24th of this
year he said that there was only one
deputy on scene on the school during the
entire attack that's proven to be false
so he can't tell the truth about that
event then he goes on a town forum and
he blames the NRA then he blames one
deputy Scott Peterson for this problem
then he blames everybody else that he
can for this problem I understand it he
can't be responsible for ever employee
but at the end of the day he needs to be
accountable for his employees and he's
just not being accountable and yes this
is some of the reasons why he needs to
be removed from office removed from
office and so accountability requires
transparency you have to know what
someone's doing in order to evaluate it
and you just heard trace Gallagher say
that there are many video and audio
tapes that the public still has not seen
why is that well they don't want to be
transparent because it's going to expose
that the sheriff knew some information
in the past that he contradicted himself
in public interviews and that's going to
come back and bite him on that however
we're gonna press forward for more
transparency with the sheriff the same
way that he claims to be the most
transparent sheriff that's ever been in
the sheriff's office it goes both ways
sheriff and you need to be transparent
release those videos so we can know the
truth now if there's vote of
no-confidence goes forward and it turns
out the way that the membership is
voicing their opinion towards us then
we'll take that information to the
governor's office and we'll support him
with ever whatever decision he wants to
make but if he chooses to remain sheriff
with Scott Israel then that means that
the governor agrees that sheriff Israel
is an amazing leader which he's not and
before warned that when a next incident
happens if the governor leaves him there
it will be on the hands of Governor
Scott not the employees at the Broward
Sheriff's Office well I'm so glad you're
bringing this to our attention it's a
shame though we had to wait months to
hear it from a law enforcement officer
and at CNN which hosted this gun-control
rally and put Israel at the center of it
never asked a single skeptical question
about his behavior it's frustrating but
I'm glad the truth is coming out and I'm
glad you're telling our viewers about it
mr. Bell thank you thank you